jean-daniel joyel vous êtes diplômé
d'études supérieures vous êtes licencié
en philosophie en 46 vous étiez attachés
au cabinet de la présidence du conseil
et puis tout à coup vous êtes dirigés
vers journalisme pour quelles raisons
après la prise de la présidence du
consulat lisez ça on sait simplement
parce que je pensais pouvoir m'affirmer
plus rapidement je pensais écrire à
l'époque parce que c'était pas un
véritable journalisme je suis rentré
dans une agence très obscur où il y
avait des gens qui sont devenus depuis
célèbre pierre vincent le coach jean
louis guilloux et puis c'est la société
générale de presse ce qui publiait des
des bulletins rené ôté et anonyme
si c'était pour moi un gagne pas avec
l'idée que j'allais écrire pour moi
comme on disait quand on avait cet âge
non mes premiers ambition c'était de
devenir écrivain
non je voulais pas faire du journalisme
sauf complémentaires et je voulais être
un écrivain qui deviennent journaliste
qui exprime aussi dans les journaux et
vous êtes plutôt devenir journaliste qui
fait des livres
bon alors vous êtes directeur du nouvel
observateur il faut le rappeler et vous
publié aux éditions grasset un ouvrage
est titulaire des ruptures en phase de
groupe jean françois revel des agrégés
philosophie il était professeur vous de
1905 en 1963 donc pendant 13 ans vous
êtes l'auteur d'une douzaine de livres
dont vous êtes l écrivain et vous
raconter dans la préface du livre dont
nous parlerons tout à l'heure que
lorsqu'il ya 25 ans le premier numéro de
l'express est parue vous l'avez acheté
comme un simple lecteur car vous n'étiez
pas journaliste à ce moment là et puis
aujourd'hui vous êtes directeur de
l'express
donc là une évolution étonnante
qu'est-ce qui a fait que l'écrivain et
le professeur sont devenus journalistes
vous avez le cours des choses parce que
d'abord entre jusqu'à l'âge de 32 33 ans
que j'ai passés à peu près la moitié de
ma vie hors de france au mexique en
italie aux états unis donc une pas
question pour moi de songer même très
loin johnny journaliste enfant cependant
ces ces années où j'ai vécu à l'étranger
j'ai écrit un certain nombre de livres 3
exactement pourquoi des philosophes pour
l'italie et c'est que j'ai publié quand
je suis rentré en france en 1957 c'est
le fait que j'aie qui ces livres qui a
fait que des directeurs de journaux mon
demandez des articles et que
j'ai participé de plus en plus
étroitement à la rédaction des journaux
et leurs à l'élaboration c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi vu on itinéraire
personnel quand je vois des jeunes gens
qui me disent a priori je voudrais
devenir journaliste je ne comprends pas
très bien parce que pour moi c'est un
processus tout à fait insensible et
j'avoue que j'ai même hésité très
longtemps a quitté l'enseignement
pendant plusieurs années j'ai vu qu'ils
ont mené de front les deux activités
vous êtes là ce soir pour un ouvrage
vous avez préfacé que s'intitule express
aventures du vrai qui positionne à
michel qui est un recueil d'articles
important par le parus durant les c'est
à dire oui c'était un grand appartement
à paris
et puis à côté de vous guy hocquenghem
mélodies hothead games qui est à
libération et la libération annoncée
très joliment l'émission d'aujourd'hui
je lis sur les intellectuels
journalistes
notre éminent collaborateur guy
hocquenghem pour son livre la beauté du
métis et livré au bayern sacré de la
presse jean daniel pour l'oeuvre jf
revel pour l'express et georges suffert
du point comment va-t-il s'en tirait
comment va-t-il s'habiller suspens
comment a t'il s'habiller on sait déjà
l'autre question répond à tout à l'heure
alors mais vous vous êtes professeur de
philosophie à l'université de 26 ans
chargé de cours à sanitaire vous
enseigner la philosophie vincennes vous
êtes écrivain est vrai journaliste à
libération et sous cause et qui sont
trois activités intellectuellement
complémentaires non c'est pas
complémentaires ce qui avec toute façon
je suis pas prend vraiment je suis
chargé de cours ce qui est tout à fait
un petit post je dis un truc qui
rapporte pas assez de fric pour pour
gagner sa vie
bon je suis à libération à libération on
gagne tous deux mille sept cents vols
par mois et pour moi c'est important de
gagner 2704 pour moi d'abord vous le
dire et puis d'autre part il ya des
choses que je peux dire dans libération
qu'on pourrait que je pourrais pas dire
autrement
toutes ces choses sur des sujets doivent
être abordés sur les immigrés sur les
rapports avec l'enfance et c'est que je
pense que qu'on peut dire que dans un
journal comme libera s'est jamais
imaginé que vous gagnez davantage notre
vie à libération est ce que vous
abandonneriez le carrière professoral
j'ai pas de carrière première pause pour
ses ambitions de devenir professeur n'en
prennent pas du tout du tout vous
risquez d'abandonner donc
je sais pas j'ai pas une carrière je
pense pas en terme de carrière je veux
dire c'est mal barré sinon si on
commence comme ça parce que bon j'ai été
chargé de cours à vincennes comme tous
les chargés coréen scène parce que
j'étais à mille temps en mai 68 et je
suis à libé exactement de la même façon
pour faire une carrière de journaliste
bien georges suffert bon je dis vous
avez toujours été jouée ici moment non
au départ les fonctionnaires économique
l'éthéphon crise économique il devrait
passer au journalisme
parce que me proposait de deux prônent
témoignage chrétien qui était il y avait
une forme sur ce rédacteur en chef on me
le proposait oui bon alors vous c'est un
peu le l'itinéraire inverse
parce que vous êtes vous êtes au point
vous vous dirigez la rubrique it et vous
vous êtes donc j'irai l'intellectuel
numéro un du point et vous avez vous
avez écrit des ouvrages des essais genre
on se rappelle banques des pamphlets
comme les intellectuels en chaise longue
le cadavre de dieu bouge encore et puis
à 50 ans de publier votre premier livre
de fiction alors que jean daniel lui le
son premier livre a été un roman qui
qu'est-ce que pourquoi 50 ans + vient au
leadership n'est ce pas ce qu'on a mais
marc du ronron des idées peut-être parce
que la politique m'emmerde
peut-être parce que j'ai toujours eu
envie d'écrire et que je me suis dit des
cris des cris réellement quoi c'est à
dire pas ne peut pas ne pas être
uniquement journalistes et qui jamais
osé par une espèce de respect bizarre la
littérature qui pour moi est une des
choses les plus importantes et donc
j'avais peur de rentrer dans ce domaine
et puis à 50 ans je me suis dit on peut
peut-être y aller ça plus important ce n
est pas de vraie frontière n'est pas il
n'ya pas surtout pour les reporter c'est
un saut de faire de l'éditorial revendre
mais pour l'épauler lors porter moi moi
j'ai fait toute ma vie du reportage
jamais senti que la frontière avec le
romanesque était et orge ou alors la
fête au togo et autres histoires sont
cette nouvelle vous fait paraître aux
éditions
grasset et il m'a semblé que
dénominateur commun de ces nouvelles
c'était je dirais la recherche la quête
de quelque chose de caché quelque chose
parfois même qui touche à la
métaphysique
oui mais on va pas ennuyer tout le monde
avait alors comment dire deux mots
disons qu'on peut chercher dit en
rigolant
moi c'est ce qui m'intéresse mais je
crois qu'il faut pas ennuyer les gens
avec ça parce que ça les embête lui sa
jambe est donc ce mot va faire à moi
tout seul alors j'essaie de raconter des
histoires qui sont des histoires de deux
personnages qui me paraissent et des
espèces de saint de notre époque mais ça
ne se voit pas hun sen par définition
n'a pas de rival sur la tête
alors j'en ai rencontré quelques-uns
j'essaie de faire des histoires et qu'
il ya un curieux général par exemple qui
est qui ressemble au général de gaulle
et qui en vérité n'est pas général de
gaulle et qui est plein d'admiration
pour jeudi en deux mots cette histoire
du général parce que elle est
extraordinaire tout le monde me dit que
c'est vraiment inouïe d'avoir arrangé
une histoire aussi fausse la seule
embêtements c'est qu'elle est
intégralement vrai de la première à la
dernière ligne et qui est sur les rails
or j'aime mieux pas dire son nom mais
morne mais c'est ingérable daf étonnant
c'est un fils du peuple et ses histoires
de rotatives qu'on envoie en afrique et
qu'on implante sur un lieu sacré et puis
elle ne marche pas on envoie les
ingénieurs les agit en dise non elle
barge tout va bien le circuit électrique
est parfait je vois la main de ballots
parce que
on croit que j'ai de l'imagination mais
il est vrai la rotative
oui ça qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour la
faire marcher finalement eh ben on a tué
1 poule ex voulu qu'ils fassent mme
lacuey un poulet pour et on a arrosé de
sang de poulet et au porteur c'est du
reportage alors je mangeais deux ou
trois petites choses pour que c'est que
ça a l'air de la fiction mais finalement
en ce moment je suis à londres
je suis pas ici je viens d'arriver et je
repars demain matin 8 heures quelle
élection en angleterre mais depuis trois
jours j'ai quatre nouvelles que je
ramasse dont je pourrais rien faire
comment voulez vous les mettre dans des
articles c'est tellement inouïe
j'ai demandé tonné en une phrase fils
demandé au chauffeur de m'emmener à un
endroit qui soit à londres
relativement pauvre mais pas trop dans
lequel se trouve la basse classe moyenne
que le voit comment sont faits des
maisons et les terrains et il m'a amené
un endroit il ma promesse était
absolument merveilleux et à la fin il a
arrêté la voiture il m'a dit excusez moi
je vais me laver les mains il est chez
lui c'est tout l effet la nouvelle dans
un temps c'est un peu vous aussi les
personnages lorsque vous dit à l'époque
jeunes hurlaient déjà plus avec les
loups mais je siffle encore avec les
forains c'est pas beau c'est un
personnage qui dit sa douce mélodie de
la sottise les mots clés les formule
passe partout les références admises les
titres de films ou de livres et maliens
la banalité des secours voilà ce qui
composait mon univers intellectuel et
moral n'est pas un peu vous qui parlez
là seul bien possible me sort allez
savoir
et jean daniel vous avez lu ce livre
d'abord je trouve comme tout à l'heure
lorsque je vous disais tout à l'heure
que le reportage est fait de l'art de
conter d'abord et avant tout je veux
dire avant la vision politique avant
l'option avant le camp on se place et
que est de plain pied d'un seul coup
mais moi j'ai pas les pas saluer la
conversion de super comme toute la
critique parce que
j'ai toujours vu dans ses reportages
l'épreuve qu'il avait qu'il possédait
l'art du récit et que je encore une fois
surtout par la nouvelle alors peut-être
que jonathan ou grands moments mais
peut-être pour la nouvelle je veux dire
c'est à la portée dans le reportage et
le sens de la couleur le sens de
l'observation
le sens de l'image et et ce sont les
trois sens qu'il faut devenir pour la
nouvelle et je trouve en tout cas pour
la première que je préfère à toutes
celles qui donne son titre au recueil
avec sa chute et rage entre juifs et
noirs
je trouve que là il ya tous les éléments
du grand reportage au sens où d'ailleurs
les romanciers america l'entendait qui
ont été d'abord de reporter ayant
effectivement les nouvelles de grand
reporter puisque je crois que sur les 7
1 à 6 qui se passe à l'étranger je suis
bien content et guy hocquenghem est ce
que vous allez dans votre lit dont on
reparlera loges dont j'ai oublié le type
de la beauté du mettis réflexion des
francophones qui paraît aux éditions du
ram ça et vous en prenez avec très
grande violence au ton français souffre
on sait que su faire et dans le bon ton
français a tout à fait jamais une chose
tu as l'air vous avez dit qu'est ce qui
fait la différence entre les reporters
et les écrivains à moi je pense qu'en
fait pour un livre comme celui de ses
serres cgt exceptée
je pense qu'il n'aurait jamais été
publié c'est super était pas militaria
listel directeur d'un grand magazine en
l'occurrence le point je pense qu'en
fait il ya un clip de littérature
française tout à fait typique qui est
celle qui s'assure une édition par la
position de pouvoir des gens qui
écrivent des bouquins je pense qu'il ya
comme ça des fous romancier défaut
nouvelliste défaut écrivains qui sont
simplement des gens font également de
pouvoir oser faire éditer et que ce
faire on est un cas absolument typique
je suis fait du mieux possible à partir
du moment où on écrit
on ne fait pas du rhône alpes sur deux
rails je me défendrai mais là dessus pas
du tout je peux pas me défendre ils
peuvent en raison qu'il ya une chose en
plus il suffit serait pas aussi
masochiste ou su faire d'abord parce que
ça ne m'intimide pas ensuite parce que
je lui avec un grand plaisir un grand
bonheur le livre de guillaume engel mais
que je trouve que rien n'est plus
classique n'est plus français de plus
parisien que ce merveilleux petit fleuve
petit pamphlet je suis un lecteur de
libération
j'ai trouvé une différence très grande
et je ne trouve pas qu'il se soit avec
sens que je vous dise est un constat
entre le style libération vous avez dans
vos articles que je tourne d'ailleurs eu
et tulle ans et ce style merveilleux
mais tellement classique dans le bonheur
d'expression au sens où êtes heureux
d'écrire mais vous avez une cravate que
vous écrivez de cianci alors le pouvoir
là dedans je sais pas où il est moi je
trouve d'ailleurs que le peuple est
extrêmement intéressant j espère qu on
va parler à mme alliot marie mais là
dessus alors l'appareil que vous êtes
dans la traduction a pris les rênes à
installer ce dock finalement suffire et
ken games même combat intérieur alors
jean françois revel oui cet ouvrage au
fond c'est à travers ce nombre
d'éditoriaux 2
denquête groupe de pas fait et puis
aussi des interviews se sait la vie
politique la vie sociale française
pendant 25 ans et 25 ans d'expérience à
ce serait un peu trop ambitieux les
grands moments que je regarde ça dans le
camp moment n'ont pas forcément non plus
noah s'est pas une anthologie
c'est un salon deux coups de sonde soul
et je crois que les journaux on a
surtout plaisir à les lire
quand ils sont vieux rien n'est plus
agréable que de prendre une pile de
journaux datant dé 20 ans 40 ans 50 ans
parce qu'on est là toute la saveur de
l'époque ne sait pas quand j'écoutais
parler tout à zéro kengen g10 et voilà
il a dix ans de retard et c'est très
bien parce que c'est très typé c'est un
bon cliché ambulant de 1968 vincennes et
parle comme il faut et ça c'est très
agréable
on sait où on se trouve est avec vous
trois ans et encore mais oui mais
vraiment si vous essayez d'aller diriger
mais alors précisément je vous rends
hommage parce que je vous incarnez
parfaitement à certains trucs totalement
stéréotypées qui livre la sas et ses 68
c'était un coin aller alors on y revient
à revenir voir autant que je sache c'est
à lui qu'est chirurgie de corse et pour
moi ni pour mon jeu
non je me dire puisque aux gay games
nous traite ses vrais demande vieille
baderne annoncé parmi les jets privés
simplement il n'y en hiver par de bonnes
impressions via beaucoup de clichés dans
ce que vous dites ce que vous écrivez
vous avez dit et encore une fois les
c'est le fait souffler le reflet d'un
certain moment du temps oui alors ce
livre là ce sont des articles qui sont
pas forcément les meilleurs qui sont pas
forcément les plus significatives qui
sont ceux qui sont destinés à donner la
saveur le parfum de certaines époques de
l'histoire de l'express n'est ce pas
l'époque où mauriac écrivait chaque
semaine l'époque où jean daniel était
l'un de ces grands reporters l'époque où
albert camus a écrit des poèmes comme
indécents écrivait et j'évoque aussi que
l'intérieur oui billets mais choisi dix
ans je dirais pas à la houlette mais
enfin non forcément jeunes ont enfin les
mauriac par exemple il ya ce merveilleux
arty qui l'avait fait au moment des
élections ou que tu y es devenu par la
publie un article extraordinaire rôle
mais il lui était impossible encore une
fois d'être équitable ce qui est amusant
c'est évidemment c'est de la variété des
signatures parce qu'on y trouve
effectivement jean-daniel mais on y
trouve gens qu audi trouve mendès france
jean-jacques servan-schreiber team et
dépens d'autres parce que je peux poser
une question d'après vous quel est le
lien entre les trois experts qui se sont
succédé eh bien je crois que le lien est
donné par le
par le titre c'est à dire c'est à dire
quelque chose qui se vend non c'est à
dire la bonne aventure du vrai nom moi
je vous dis ça et pourquoi il ya
cinquante années
oui je le contester la hausse ont testé
dix ans la presse que la qualification
fessionnels l'express si vous commettez
d'abord comme des pros qu'un esprit
polémique
simplement quand j'ai vu ce qui était
d'ailleurs pour moi plutôt flatteur mais
non là dedans je me suis je ressentais
une certaine gêne mais j'attends des
autorités suisses à lille cedex
je voudrais plus d'interview en
interview et je vais analyser cette
jeune et je me suis dit au four
moi je suis rentré tout à l'heure vous
m'avez demandé pour le journalisme on
vrais débuts dans le journalisme c'était
la guerre d'algérie je suis je n'ai fait
de vrai journal il a bon dos dans tout
le reste que pour tes moyens sur la
guerre le jeu à ce moment là l'express
j'aurais opinion enfin d'ailleurs à ce
moment là jean françois revel un peu
plus tard un peu occupé au journal où je
suis l'obstacle s'arrêter en des
fonctions importantes et d une animation
que je respecte et que nos spect ouais
ce journal au bout de neuf années de
journal d'opinion qu'il était inchangé
et je vous souvienne
déjeuner avec jean-jacques
servan-schreiber où il m'a dit
maintenant on va pouvoir faire des news
magazines
j'ai dit bon ben moi je partirai famille
était là pour autre chose et je vous
comprends s'est séparé comme ça c'était
un autre journal tout de même il restait
un point commun c'était gerland que ça
va durer ensuite il ya eu des équipes et
si on me demandait et rue des
transmissions et ses équipes de
transmission au fait que les gros titres
restés mais les équipes ont complètement
changé puisque la fondation du point il
ya eu le départ de l'équipe pour
l'occident si on me demandait de réagir
par les flammes en frappant c'est quand
les failles parce que les actuels sont
alimentés par des anciens d'exposer
quelques curieux 5 et 3 avril tous les
trois c'est même assez étrange seule
julie benz est tous les trois de
l'express fondamentale et beaucoup de
gens de gauche au mieux vous dire ce
prêt n'ait pas été informée nous
appelons jour de terminer voir une seule
journée niel une seule phrase que nous
demande de comprendre si on me demande
puisque vous avez tels observateurs de
faire un livre avec tous les articles
dont les vôtres en glanant laventure
deux pas du beau du bien et avec le
titre l'observateur
moi je serai
je crois que quelque chose que
j'aimerais surtout qu'il ya eu passation
il ya plus de points communs apprête à
vrai dire il ya peut-être team et de
roger puisqu'il son innovation les
points communs ne sont pas seulement les
patins personnels à la banque est
d'abord de ce pas d'abord d'abord un
journal qui l'histoire se déroule sur un
quart de siècle il ya forcément des
changements et je n'ai pas quand vous
dites il ya plus de points communs
il y en a un certain nombre d'oublier
pas que moi-même je suis entré à
l'express en 1966 vous vient d'ailleurs
à l'époque où vous vous avez créé
l'observateur sensiblement le cas donc
je chante 5 je suis parti à tort c'est à
dire des raisons plus grande et dormi et
pendant en tant que point commun par
exemple de continuité de l'express
mon histoire à l'express est aussi lent
que la vôtre d'observateurs oui mais
alors fallu la faire débuter de votre
entrée je trouve que vous aviez toi tu
donnes tout à l'heure que non j'avais 10
ans de retard non parce que quand on
vous voit vous en êtes en fait enfin de
vous disputer de passer de l'express
cet ehpad le nombre d'abonnés dont je
savais tout facile très loin ce lundi
que ce vent ou se transmet ou ou bien
ces rites mais c'est pas nous passer la
main il s'agit de savoir si quand on
sait aujourd'hui c'est le cas où son
club savate et je peux tu qu'il est roi
du nord avec deux mois je n'assume pas
son passé ses huit partenaires kg m'a
dit que j'assumais ce livre est une
anthologie pourquoi est-ce que vous
parlez il sort d'assumer n'est ce pas il
s'agit de faire de l'histoire
vous comprenez bon on les gens exagèrent
de l'histoire et dans la préface que je
fais je la première phase
ma première phase consiste à dire il
serait présomptueux de ma part de
prétendre patronne et un passé qui donc
pour une grande partie je ne suis pas
responsable et qui représente une
période où j'étais simplement à lecteurs
de l'express jamais jamais écrit dans
aucun journal je m'empresse de dire je
suis le premier à le dire mais c'est pas
une raison mais moi personnellement je
suis pas égocentrique tué palier
l'histoire l'express à moi c'est
peut-être ce que je dirige maintenant
j'estime que si on fait un livre pour le
25e anniversaire de l'express
d'électeurs ont le droit de lire des
articles antérieurs mon arrivée ici pas
mégalomane à ce point face à vous savez
bien que le problème est alors je suis
ferme n'est pas simplement
un coup je suis resté des neuf ans
l'express aussi alors ils en viennent
tous j'étais quand et cet officier qui
sont tous les trois directeurs des
journaux les trois d'une même journée
avoir su podium à mon âge du fer n'est
pas de la pression migratoire ya lille
et deuxièmement c'est pas vrai problème
est que je te fais un terreau de sa
parcelle en genre de chose si vous
permettez
oui j'avais quelque chose dans le nouvel
express et c'est pourquoi je ne le renie
absolument pas et je pense que
simplement que le point harry sera
réussir à faire mieux que le pressent de
plus en plus c'est autre chose mais ce
que j'ai appris et qui est
extraordinairement dense un des fentes
abouti abonnez vous non ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est parce que je ne le
savais pas bon c'est à quel point le
journalisme est une bataille pour
arriver à reconstituer l'événement dans
la plus grande précision possible
je ne savais pas avant l'express et je
vais a pris dans un peu dans le nouvel
express avant j'étais plus
éditorialisant si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire
à partir de ce moment là ça a changé au
fond on pouvait les portes
c'est vrai que tu y mets
et là et de roger aussi et la sphère
benbarka pour lui il la connaît il croit
qu'il la connaît mais c'est parce que
c'est au début
au début on est quatre à chercher
simplement quelqu'un qui est un copain
de beaux habits tu connais bien qui est
ben barka et dont tous croient qu'il est
venu à paris et dont on ne sait pas où
il est ça va on sait pas qu'on va faire
l'affairé ben barka
on cherche à établir quelque chose qui
va être vrai et ça va donner un article
tout le monde l'a oublié qui fait une
colonne edilivre le premier un pas plus
bon c'est tout ensuite ça va faire
750000 de tirage mais excusez moi ça
s'est bien vengé vous autant que vous
noël c'est pas vrai pourquoi pourquoi y
est roi bon c'est bien moi je vous crois
comme on dit ce que vous écrivez dans ce
livre et vous vous ne me croyez pas et
c'est pour ça que je suis musulman je ne
crois pas parce que vous êtes un homme
de pouvoir et pas moi répéter ce que
j'ai appris le goût du jour à ce que
américain george clooney revient pas de
donner une sorte de parrain travail
pratique de ce que vous appelez la
devanture du vrai mais tout à fait je
veux dire j'aurais pas de différence
entre le métier des journalistes de
métier de l'historien ça consiste à
chercher des sources à confronter les
sources d'information à vérifier les
faits bon ça c'est la base de tout et le
reste c'est du vent
le reste est du commentaire et le
commentaire est subjective heureusement
à aucun degré puis les journées donne en
ce sens avaient tous les trois des
éditorialistes et vous êtes tous les
trois aujourd'hui des gens qui
commentait presse à leur situation et
qu'on peut écrire l'éditorial sans
s'informer en profondeur en lisant les
journaux de midi jean daniel dans son
livre il exploita clairement il dit j'ai
vécu tout toute l'histoire la violence
par exemple à travers mes éditoriaux il
dit j'ai vécu mon de la chanson mais oui
je sauve des formes nouvelles et
coûteuses coûteux que joue notre jeu sur
une passe que des tonneaux vides
je le fais sur un certain nombre de
révolutions du tir ou tu sors de la
violence
ça se passe toujours à travers les
éditoriaux ces modules niyonkuru du tout
ce sujet dans ce que vous dites mais non
c'est pas gênant c'est la vérité leur la
peine de bizerte
mais écouter tous les gens qui sont ici
sont des éditorialistes c'est à dire
c'est un certain type de journal et
excusez mon patelin pour me glisser
journée ils étaient pas dit oriali steve
était d'attraper non zut je parle de
vendée vous devez par le savoir
peut-être vous savez que c'est une
certaine dignité intellectuelle que
d'apprendre voyez alors tout près
l'autre côté la police et du reportage
on va parler d'affaires précis on va
parler d'affaires curiel un peu d'eau
comme vous le savez tous enfin comme les
téléspectateurs ne savent peut-être pas
il y avait un monsieur qui s'appelait
henri curiel et qui était un grand
militant anti impérialiste ce monsieur
vous avez écrit un jour un article qui
était une ignominie temps qu'elle avait
expliqué qu' henri curiel et n 1 un
agent du kgb sait très bien que cet
article était tellement du monde à 32
journalistes y compris dans votre
journal ont été gênés au point d'avoir
envie de démissionner notre journal
c'est ce qui est arrivé à henri curiel
après il était assassiné n'avait jamais
rectifier ce que vous aviez écrit sont
henri curiel c'est ça le métier de
journaliste c'est ça le métier d'un
formateur vous avez traité henri curiel
d'agents du kgb il a été assassiné et
encore aujourd'hui vous n'avez jamais
démentie ce que j'avais écrit le spiegel
a fait la même chose que vous eux au
moins ils ont démenti ils ont envoyé a
démenti effectivement et ils ont publié
un démenti là dessus bon ce type de
pratique là c'est la pratique du
journalisme je forrester des grands
journalistes français alors venez pas la
ramener avec la faire une barque d'âge
georges suffert je vais vous répondre
très simplement je crois que nous ne
sommes jamais ils ne sont pas ce que
vous écrivez et qu'il ya toujours des
conséquences dans ce qu'on écrit je ne
sais pas c'est ce que j'écris sur
l'affairé sur l'algérie sur l'indochine
n'ai pas eu des conséquences que je suis
incapable de mesurer et quand j'étais à
témoignage chrétien c'était le premier
hebdomadaire où j'étais quand nous avons
publié les premiers textes sur la
torture c'étaient les premiers qui
paraissait
je veux dire que j'ai pas dormi par un
certain nombre de jours pour une raison
stupide ce que je respectais l'armée
française et que dire quelle torture est
ça me paraissait pas simple les
conséquences de ce que j'écris je les
connais pas je ne les connais jamais y
en a eu pour attendre et à l'enchère
attendait il n'y a pas de différence de
nature pour moi dans la sphère curiel
sur lequel j'ai travaillé pendant quatre
mois et sur ce que j'aime et je pense
que vous avez travaillé autant de temps
que moi et que vous en savez ils ont
travaillé tant de temps pour savoir
qu'est ce que vous avez dit à l'époque
était un mensonge éhonté et a
probablement participé d'un complot qui
a bouté assassinat de curial je n'en
sais rien lui sait que faire des
affirmations personne aujourd'hui ne ne
prétendrai plus que réel est un agent du
kgb ou presque rien car il est
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous le fait d
oui ou non je dis que moi je n'en sais
rien bon je n'en savais rien je vous
demande de vous ce que vous savez je dis
que plus aucun journal aujourd'hui nous
a imprimé une affirmation gratuite
jeudi je vous demande où vial des
lentilles inverse vous aviez à appliquer
ce faire vous a posé une question
précise il vous a demandé quel est votre
enquête sur le sujet je vais écouter ci
si désagréable que soit le fait de me
désolidariser d'avec ou 3 alors qu'il
veut nous vendre solidaire je dois dire
que de la sphère curiel j'ai tout de
présomptions presque des preuves que
qu'il était innocent et je ne dis pas le
contraire aurait demandé un témoignage
joly
ce qui ne veut pas dire absolument que
je viens cuse mon confrère un super
d'avoir une responsabilité quelconque
dans cette affaire mais sur ce plan
point précis je crois que l'on peut dire
je crois que je suis à peu près sûr
qu'on peut dire que curiel est utilisée
parce que c'est ce que je voulais dire
c'est ce site le choix se dit
l'opération sur le problème il se met en
rapport avec la violence et la journée
on voit qu'il est très précisément ceux
ci s'étaient tout le monde peut se
tromper le problème n'est pas là que
nous ne peut se tromper en donnant une
information que le problème est que
quelqu'un qui de fait a donné une
information fausse information qui peut
avoir eu avoir été en relation avec de
très graves conséquences en traîneau
mort d'homme non seulement ne se reprend
jamais mais même continue à dire la même
chose et ça c'est très grave
et ça c'est une pratique de journaliste
que je trouve scandaleux
georges suffert vous répandez on passe
ensuite au dojo répond en disant que
pour moi il n'ya rien n'a changé à ce
que j'ai écrit et que j'ai une confiance
considérable dans une vieille chose qui
s'appelle l'histoire progressivement les
choses sortent et sept-îles d'état de
vérité commence à apparaître
j'ai tout mon temps pour le moment vous
dit une chose et l'événement viendront
progressivement vous démontrez vous avez
tort non ça non seulement car également
brancher un bon alors je m'en servais
elle vous dites dans votre présentation
dans une préface que l'express n'est pas
un journal partisan
que voulez-vous dire non je veux dire
sur les cas des journaux qui ont une
ligne politique bien précise qui
soutiennent soit qui à partir d'un parti
politique
terminer si vous voulez qu'ils sont
chargés très officiellement très
ouvertement de défendre la politique les
partis politiques de formation ce
quelques la disant d'humanité ce qui est
le cas de la lettre de la nation c'est
quelqu'un de l'unité soit qui ont ils
ont des sympathies politiques affirmer
qu'ils descendent d'un programme
politique précis ce qui pourrait être
salvateur et j'avais été le cas de l'ex
prince au début et ce qui était le cas
d'élection ses débuts encore qu'il
s'agissait pas d'une formation politique
déterminée attention l'express non plus
que l'option vote non enfin vous avez
quand même pris position des gens pour
le programme commun pour l'union de la
gauche vraiment brune mais comme
l'express a mis le bonnet phrygien pour
repos à l'époque mais je suis tout à
fait d'accord selon l'express si vous
voulez n'a pas gelé mais pourquoi you
really rejet n'étant d'ailleurs nous sur
en fait évident non mais là il ya pas de
polémique entre nom étant donné que les
opinions de partisans il n'est plus une
seconde une seconde non cette entrevue
c'est pas vrai du tout c'est pas nous
c'est toujours chaud face aux rebelles
non ce que je veux dire en somme c'est
que quand vous lisez l'humanité vous
savez d'avancé qui va être écrit par
exemple sur
l'afghanistan où l'invasion du cambodge
par le vietnam bien vous savez d'avant
ce qui va être dit à propos de la
politique étrangère de l'europe bon ce
qui distingue ils ont un journal que
j'appelle nos partisans ce n'est pas du
tout en un qui ne prend pas parti et
d'ailleurs depuis que je dirais ce
journal nous avons pris parti et très
vigoureusement pour un certain nombre de
choses bien et nous avons pris et non
publié des documents qui ce qu'est ce
qui constituait des engagements et des
responsabilités et ça veut pas les durs
dire non plus que c'est un journal dans
lequel on n'exprime pas d'opinion
puisqu'elle des éditoriaux et qu'elle
n'a même plus qu'avant je veux dire tout
simplement que la ligne n'est pas fixée
qu'elles résultent de est d'ailleurs
qu'elle est loin d'être unanime à
l'intérieur du journal etc et une
diversité chose qui ce qui se reflète la
preuve par exemple c'est qu'à la veille
du premier tour des élections
législatives et bien olivier toile a
publié un éditorial pour dire qu'il
fallait voter socialiste et que j'ai
personnellement publié un éditorial pour
dire qu'il ne fallait pas voter pour le
programme commun donc c'est ça que je
veux dire journal disons n'ayant pas une
clientèle a priori vers ça se reflète
parmi les lecteurs si vous voulez on ne
voit dans le courrier où il ya des
lecteurs qui viennent aussi bien du rpr
que des partis communistes que du sens
etc et suivant les positions qu'on prend
sur tel ou tel problème
eh bien on se fait approuver au
contraire réprouvée par telle ou telle
catégorie de lecteurs
jean-daniel l'ère des ruptures départ
votre livre vous racontez donc la
création du nouvel observateur fait
d'une équipe qui venait d'une du france
observateur une autre équipe qui venait
de l'express et vous dites que votre
ambition au départ l'idée de faire un
bon journal de réussir ce journal ce que
vous avez fait d'ailleurs mais aussi de
rassembler la gauche
et puis votre livre s'intitule l'ère des
ruptures à ce que c'est pas là l'aveu de
ce côté là d'un échec
écoutez le livre c'est un de volonté
d'inventaire pendant 15 années où il
s'est passé dans le monde des
changements considérables l'équipe a
changé le journal a changé le monde a
changé
c'était une tentative de faire sur
modestement sur quelques points
fondamentaux
c'est le bilan de ces changements nous
étions une équipe en effet nous sommes
parti de rien après un jeu dur de rien
vraiment un sale époque et avec des
expériences où nous avons tous je
reprends parce que ça mais ça m'est
extrêmement c'est essentiel pour moi
nous avons à peu près tous dans l'équipe
dans une certaine équipe du de départ
connu la violence sur le terrain ce que
peu de gens qui en part en ce moment
connaissent et pas à travers des
articles d'éditoriaux nous avons vu
quelques fois des témoins ou en
participant un certain nombre de
révolutions dans les théâtres
d'opération et nous avons participé
nous avons contribué même un la mystique
tiers-mondiste avec plus ou moins de
bonheur avec plus ou moins d'erreurs
avec plus ou moins de réussite
et à une époque où la gauche n'existait
pas et où par une sorte de transfert
d'exil de la pensée se projeter dans le
tiers-monde toutes les espérances d'une
jeunesse qui ne trouvaient pas en france
le projet révolutionnaire nous avons
voulu essayer de stimuler sur les flancs
de la gauche qui n'était pas encore
officielle ils sortent de marginalité
subversive et très vite liste nos
ambitions été dépassé de nous voulions
faire un journal tout à fait restreinte
à fait modeste et je trouve que ça
coïncidait avec une attente mon livre à
l'heure actuelle c'est comme je vous le
disais le besoin de rendre des côtes
un journal effet il faut que les gens
sachent comment la changer même si les
lecteurs ont accepté au fur et à mesure
les changements
c'est au fond une sorte de deux constats
de deux rapports voilà quinze ans après
voilà ce que nous sommes devenus voilà
pourquoi ils comment nous avons fait
elle état de chose est sûre les exemples
précis sur des agences et sur le génie
jeans et la sphère du portugal c'est
sur ces 7 de gaulle c'est la
décolonisation c'est un certain nombre
de thèmes pendant ces 15
il faut bien voir je veux dire les
changements sans son vertige et de on
est parti dans une ambiance
productiviste où les américains comme
les russes lutte et un coup de chiffres
pour savoir qui dans les années à venir
allez avoir le produit national vos jeux
les plus élevés ou nous vous les ans la
plus grande
on est passé dans une période où tout à
fait en t ils y tiennent nantais mai 68
et où tout l'espoir des gens c'était la
machine à laver et le réfrigérateur
l'automobile avec l'idée que les
matières premières de notre époque le
même temps le pétrole manquait jamais on
est par contre on assiste aujourd'hui à
7,7
ce résumé intense de changement qui fait
que je leur ai l'inventaire serait trop
trop trop trop long je résumerais d'une
seule manière je sylla changement
fondamental entre il ya quinze ans
maintenant c'est que les gens ne croient
plus dans l'avenir
il ya une enquête qui a été fait aux
états unis et qui y va énormément
impressionné
on a demandé aux jeunes gens dans l'état
le plus je veux dire le texas c'est à
dire on a choisi l'état où la prospérité
matérielle était censé garantir les gens
et leur donner une sorte de projet alors
à poser la question et vous est-ce que
vous pensez que demain soit meilleur
qu'aujourd'hui 50% répondu non c'est à
dire dans l'état le plus pauvre
productiviste dans l'état où le mythe de
la productivité de confiance en l'avenir
de la confiance dans le progrès dans la
science productiviste est le plus grand
je crois que ce symbole est des plus
importants c'est un indicatif
c'est un clignotant jeu signalé jean
petaux les sondages et 30 ans donc
toujours loin de répondre aux questions
dans cet état je les gens lorsque les
réponses à ce qu'on vit mieux maintenant
il ya dix ans et toujours oui est ce
qu'on vivra mieux dans 10 à leur
maintenance et sa trompette et
comparatifs et nous en avons
eric est tous les volumes des galas bien
sûr c'était un comparatif avec le même
un même sondage avec les mêmes questions
dans le même dans la même région
50 et le pourcentage des gens qui
n'avaient plus confiance en l'avenir
avait augmenté de 12
ah oui et non jean daniel
ils sont bien 15 ans vous étiez plus
idéaliste qu'aujourd'hui que vous êtes
aujourd'hui plus réaliste vous mettez il
ya 15 ans car il ya quatre ans dit cette
phrase terrible que vous avez souligné
d'ailleurs parce qu'elle est en italie
qu il ya désastreuse expérience ces
trente dernières années nous conduit à
comprendre toutes les révoltes mais en
même temps de faire confiance à aucune
révolution
écoutez ça dépend ce que vous appelez
égalise mais réalise puisque je veux pas
revenir de tout de même que ce que vous
oubliez tout à leurs échecs
les chèques pour moi au niveau je
profite allègrement pleinement
complètement du fait d'être indépendant
de toute espèce de partie donc pour moi
la victoire ça consiste à remplacer un
gouvernement par une autre fut-il
socialiste communiste radicale de gauche
par n'importe quel rpf ou le contraire
la victoire à caen c'est ça ce
consisterait en une véritable
instauration d'un changement de
structure qui conduirait un socialiste
dans la liberté ce sont des monts sauf
quand ils sont définis un petit peu plus
si vous voulez à une à des structures
qui conduira chaque individu à trouver
le maximum d'épanouissement
alors ça c'est plus simple c'est plus
vrai ça peut mieux être réalisé avec une
limitation progressive est considérable
de tous les pouvoirs de l'état
eh bien on a vu que la gauche avait
dispensé elle le fait d'ailleurs depuis
le siècle des lumières depuis la
révolution française la rouge et or 19e
siècle s'en occuper le pouvoir dispose à
la nation qu'à la france ses valeurs
éternelles à peu près tout le temps dire
on a vu que
qu'est ce que nous sommes qu'est ce que
nous voulions faire nouveau début de
l'express et où est ce que j'ai voulu
faire au début de l'observateur avec
d'autres c'est être les héritiers des
eaux la deûle affaire dreyfus de
voltaire de l' affaire calas
l'introduction de l'intellectuel et de
la morale dans une certaine politique
donc la victoire de ceci tu paies ou la
défaite se situe pas là ouvre la place
et à leur nom sacré mental idéal il est
positif mais ya rupture est pour alors
quand à l'idéal il ne réalise et au fait
qu l'une des grandes découvertes de ces
quinze dernières années
c'est ce constat que la gauche
socialiste ou pas doit faire à savoir
que le capitalisme pour les nations qui
printemps du socialisme sens capable de
susciter les mêmes aliénation les mêmes
exploitation et maintenant nous le
savons les mêmes guerre à l'égalité il
n'y a pas un camp qui se réclament d'une
idéologie et qui serait innocent de ces
mots ce constat était extrêmement
important il faut aller jusqu'au bout
des conséquences de ce constat était
vraiment égalité je les ouvre aimait
vraiment régalé je vais même un petit
peu plus loin en ce sens que je veux
répondre à la question de bernard pivot
sur les révolutions la tentative de ce
livre si si on a eu une enfin l'ambition
secrète du livre puisque je ne m'attache
aussi raconter des histoires je
m'attache à je manque reçurent des
élites et des phénomènes ponctuels
leur mission se classe au lycée
d'essayer de réfléchir pourquoi les des
révolutions alors qu'elles sont
destinées toujours à être domptée par le
totalitarisme
depuis le temps où je lis des livres des
auteurs qui veut dit que côté couronne
ont fait la révolution côté jardin on
sort dans le goulag et de tous les pays
je voudrais essayer d'aller plus loin
pour savoir pourquoi on fait quand même
des révolutions et celles non mon
ambition c'est d'approché à la fois dans
sur la planète et en france le fait par
exemple la permanence d'une mystique
révolutionnaire au parti communiste
même si
les verbale et pourquoi avoir livré ses
déboires qui sont confirmées inventorié
décrit il n'y a pas une rumeur qui
circule dans le monde il n'y a pas un
bouche à oreille parmi les victimes de
ces révolutions pour se dire non pas
comme ça pas maintenant au fond comment
la révolte et domptée par la révolution
et comment la révolte existe toujours
c'est une chose qui me passionne
davantage que de savoir il est alerte et
tout le temps sur le fait que la
révolution autour de mal je voudrais
savoir pourquoi la révolte a lieu bien
qu'elle soit adoptée par la révolution
moi je ne vais pas gêner daniel mais
j'ai bien aimé son livre d'un bout à
l'autre et qui émanent en vélo pas plus
par l'approbation qu'il ne me gêne pas
sa désapprobation libre dessous pas tord
il était vraiment trouvé que c'était un
très beau livre d'un bout à l'autre avec
un ton d'humour caché à peine
perceptible derrière surtout dans le
récit de m est un nouvel observateur la
salade là c'est patrice là c'est à peine
cachée mais je vais pas le dire mais bon
c'est la chose dont j'ai parlé de thaler
vont peut-être peut-être que j'ai été
maladroit sur votre passé antérieur née
sept mois ce qui m'a choqué dans votre
livre c'est qu'effectivement mai 68 par
exemple ça ne passe dans votre livre
qu'à travers cette carène vraiment
minable à l'intérieur du nouvel obs qui
est une contestation de vous est ce que
j'ai voulu dire justement que vous voyez
c'est tout de même incroyable si vous
voulez que ça se réduisent a abouti à ce
gouvernement thann et soudain je
voudrais tant en tant que notre marge
brute m'en voudrez pas sur la livre non
je donne on se penche sur quelque chose
de précis sur mais je crois 80 pages de
mai 68 dans la peine 30 choses qui se
passent à l'observateur et tenter des
coups de téléphone produit net s'élève
le côté du tout et c'est derrière nous
risquions du sidaction c'est pas vrai
c'est vrai ce que les discussions avec
les gens célèbres de l'époque de savoir
si c'est mitterrand mendes moins dans le
gentil avec nous
ce genre de trucs y'a que ça dans ce
livre fait le lit des dîners en ville
bon c'est très bien vous faites les
dîners en ville c'est votre rôle
je ne dis pas que c'est le monde se le
faire simplement c'est pas la peine de
faire son arrêt des grandes phrases
sommaire rupture lors des clichés j'ai
bien vu au journal du soir et qu'il est
donc ça c'est facile ça veut dire parce
que tu sais là et c'est là c'est tout
simple parce que tout de même à travers
ta vengeance à travers tout laventure la
manière dont daniel le raconte qui est
très très prenante d'ailleurs au bout du
compte c'est tout de même l'histoire
d'un échec et je dirais pas le sien je
dirait l'autre très profondément
karam ont un autre on a tous cru d'une
manière ou d'une autre que quelque chose
était possible entre ce que nous
appelions pas encore le goulag et est ce
que nous n'aimons pas ici et c est cette
cette piste sacré chercher travers les
années à un moment se demandant si de
gaulle n'avait pas une recette derrière
la tête et jus reconnaît que c'est assez
bien de la part de daniel d'avoir dit à
un moment que finalement il avait été
très fier d'avoir comme adversaire en
face de lui
oui à chaque saison sur de gaulle oui
j'habite étonnant à l'envers et puis de
respect pour j'ai déjà ma fascination
des grands airs pour les les adjudants
et ils m'ont de cazères du coup de
gueule et et moi je pense jean trudeau
je me sens très mal à l'aise avec ce
qu'un fémur au jeu numéro un petit peu
discret au gpo soyons district de jeu
s'ajoutent les violents coups splendides
vous n'êtes pas bien j'avais dit rien de
choses je vous suggère un bouquet
d'intéressant mais il est intéressant à
cause de ses trois dernières pages je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que durant
tout le livre vous dit quelque chose
et dans trois pages vous est vachement
embêté et vous dites le contraire
il ya une espèce de la bataille éthique
moment sur la france
camouflé dans les trois dernières pages
notre cas nous le livre oui mais alors
je voudrais pas de leçon je sais très
difficile à faire
je sais on n'a pas parlé de son livre
donc on veut pas comprendre pourquoi il
ya une contradiction à la fin il nous
engueuler tout le temps on va entendre
le nom de pardon dit ça va vous êtes
tous les trois après sa 6 ou 7 salonards
d'après ce confortable installèrent
gardez vous absolument c'est vrai que
c'est très facile de faire la
journaliste n'a jamais de problème on a
nié il n'y a pas eu de problème ben
voyons
j'en ai demandé qu'on jean-daniel vous
m'ont dit que
vous dites que finalement vous vous
voyez à tort ou à raison vous l'avez
vous voyez dans la peau d'un dissident
comment expliquez vous ça parce qu
comment peut-on être directeur d'un
grand journal était osé non ils se
répondent
ça m'amuse pas tellement je veux dire je
risque de manquer du goût avec ce genre
de réflexion parce que elle n'en a pas
la portée si vous voulez essentiel de
dialogue qui mène à une sorte
d'opposition réelle fondamentale et
complète
rien n'est rien et rien n'est plus
parisien que ce livre que ces invectives
et que et que ces réflexions marginal si
le disait sur tal boissy au monde
contesté sur tel point que j'ai passé ma
vie à être contesté par les français
d'algérie par les ultra sionistes par un
certain nombre d'anti codist par les
marxistes et les trois dernières années
par les staliniens tous les gens là
dessus je vous ai solives on est plein
il part seul dîner en ville
seul m je suis pas même dropper ya pas
une seule célébrité
là dessus je plaint m parce que bon là
dessus il y à des discussions et il
j'étais je suis constamment contesté
pourquoi je dis que je suis un dissident
sais pas évidemment du rendu des
fonctions j'occupe ni serge july mon ami
nous moi même nous pouvons nous nous
pouvons être des six dissidents dans nos
fonctions nous sommes tous les deux des
directeurs il n'est pas la brosse et
juridictions de libération qui écrit des
éditoriaux ce qui manque aux équilibres
globaux et bien et bien en revanche en
revanche il a écrit un admirable
arctique sans précédent les insurgés et
un éditorial et
y'a pas de vous répondre que soeur
danielle maria callas que jamais l'heure
c'est la contestation jeudi que ce
journal qui a finalement rompu avec tous
les appareils et toutes les institutions
et qui subit toutes les contestations et
qui à l'intérieur de la gauche est
considéré comme subversif
même maintenant par le parti socialiste
et par toutes les tendances du parti
socialiste mais je trouve que ça mérite
bien sûr alors remettre en question et
si je vous promets que les paniers avec
vous une fausse bon mais ça m'est égal
comme prenait pas au sérieux par les
suivre et ça paraît assez curieux pour
moi oui dit et vous l'avais répété la
jeune observateur on s'est créé avec
rien vu on est la dissidence de ce qu'on
dépend d'aucun parti de ce terrain bon
moi je dis ça c'est pas vrai vous fait
même la comparaison avec les libérations
et charlie hebdo et vous dit de toute
façon ça s'est produit après bon pour
une raison très simple vous dites à un
moment donné
le nouvel observateur était déficitaire
jusqu'en 68000 été créés en 64 comme un
journal de cette importance des délices
père pendant quatre ans aucun soutien
financier vous sauviez sa taille et
histoire écoutez je suis désolé des
gentils nous avons eu comme des gens qui
viennent sortir maintenant
maintenant nous avons une souscription
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est que
vous voulez bien sûr il ya eu qu'à la
souscription n'y a jamais eu d'autre
argent non dans le caractère de
souscription nous avons eu tous les deux
de l'esat aux agents du mur ni reshot
juninho remy en ciblant la venue des
mois je me dis que c'est pas le même jeu
type de moonlight correct et je sais moi
il nous revient eu que vous dites
aujourd'hui arrêté jeudi
un milliard j'espérais bien bravo mais
et je n'ai aucune ombre ce qui paraît en
avoir 11 et de faire mal ce que j'ai de
les rembourser
vous n'avez pas mettre moi je vous dis
que vous mentez c'est tout bas je me
rends compte aussi que j'arrive je dis
moi que c'est pas possible de dijon
croire fait nous sommes partis la
voiture nous sommes un journal où son
parti de dieu qui part de rien de pire à
106,20 grand journal commerciales avec
les moyens d'un journal commercial c'est
normal quand vous avez repris france
observateur quand vous avez qu'audrey
une nouvelle option jeune homme comme
l'auteur d'une faute de france
observateur je vous ai fait un type de
journal qui exactement du même genre
grosso modo que l'express que le point
qui sortent tous du même moule
ce type de journal au coup de publicité
dedans bien son compte et appelle à leur
sens mais une fois des jambes de pages
de puiser dans vos différents journaux
ça y est tous très bien ce que c'est de
ce musée là c'est un type de journal
commercial je me battais de jouer aux
purs cieux je vous reproche pas de faire
un journal commerce est menacée de jouer
aux purs et aiderait en plus des leçons
en disant j'ai deux options de plus
qu'au nord des amendes qui donne de
leçons de l'aventurisme reitz et on fait
des grands journaux commerciaux dont il
ya du bon dans ces cinq week-ends que ne
comparaît pas derniers jours ni
marginaux et variétés au libération
raconté rien du tout nous sommes comme
libération comme charlie hebdo à cette
passion regarder la carte en deux
parties le jeu de rien du tout nous
avons accepté la publicité nous avons
discuté de la publicité s'est inscrit en
plus dans mon livre pour savoir sur
voulez ou pas et ce serait la
suppression des grands reportages nous
avons décidé de la maintenir et de la
contrôler et deux pas des sensations et
de séduire un peu on se demande bien où
je vais porter le nom que vous donnez à
vos aventures sur les aventures du vrai
l'ère des ruptures bon le moment là vous
dites ce que parce que ces proclamations
idéologique
bon je sais pas qui me paraît
effectivement très hypocrite c'est vrai
ce que sera ce que je pense que 700 des
journaux à nature profondément
commercial et un enracinement dans la bo
est bon alors si vous devez enfant je
voulais d'emménager j6e d'époxy moi je
trouve que ça c'est bien posture et le
voir tu as un consiste alors joué le jeu
de l'eau l'imposture ça consiste à
prendre les parures les vêtements les
oripeaux
de la marginalité pour entrer dans le
pamphlet le plus conformiste le plus
classique qui soit ya mille précédent de
vue des citations de rivarol en france
jusqu'à maintenant sur ce genre de
choses
vous savez pour être iconoclaste ce que
vous prétendez être il faudrait que des
icônes mais bon pour venir la plus d
écho la pédérastie shantotto vous avez
une grand mère juive j'en ai deux vous
avez été sur le terrain j'étais parti
qu'est ce que c'est que de quoi
qu'est-ce que je gère directeur d'un
grand journal est l'un d'eux jusqu'à 800
alors président de nous raconter quoi
est venu a pas de pitié tout à leurs
alliés vous sûr de savoir la branche de
leur poule en présentant une sort il se
rendra au futur bouquet qui est visible
dans la différence de style dès que vous
entrez dans la littérature
alors vous mettez le smoking et angie
nous est à libération et maintenant vous
faites votre numéro un du jeu produit
moi je vais vous donner à part des
autres les met une dernière question à
propos de dissidence vous êtes apparu
notamment aux yeux de pierre mendès
france vous racontez votre libre comme
dissident de la gauche parce que
vis-à-vis de gaulle vous étiez s'admire
hâtives de ces efforts pour décoloniser
non alors des colonies juives absolue
bruit bon et puis je lui mais
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que l'ail le
chapiteau là je crois que su faire leurs
bottes le chef qui est le plus étonnant
dans votre livre vous naviguez sur de
gaulle parce que là il ya un hommage à
de gaulle oui tout à fait cordiale jeudi
là dessus là dessus il ya une chose sur
lequel je me suis pas trompé une auto
sur lequel je me suis totalement trompé
je me suis pas trompé mais j'avais pas
de mérite
fréquentant les révolutionnaires
algériens et non pas les seuls au maroc
marginaux il il voulait traiter avec de
gaulle il me l'avait dit
j'étais parmi eux ils ont reconnu dès
que de gaulle est arrivé le personnage
qu'ils attendaient avec lequel il très
très tôt le choix des révolutions comme
j'avais
des images des idées des proches des
amis la famille dans les deux corps
l'histoire de la fin de la guerre pour
moi être une chose essentielle et au
départ si vous voulez y a pas eu la
fascination qui est venu équipe était
peut-être sous jacente la tante may a eu
la volonté d'aider à la fin de la guerre
d'algérie et par instruit de cette
volonté du feu l'un voulant le croire
aussi probablement par besoin de que la
paix arrive
j'ai en effet parié sur le fait que de
gaulle ferait la paix en algérie et là
j'étais dans une solitude totale puisque
autour de moi personne n'y croyait dans
ma famille spirituelle dans les courants
idéologiques dans lequel j'étais de ce
produit là langer a eu raison ou jeune
j'ai eu tort c'est que par orthodoxie
biologique par imprégnation
environnantes paru logique comment de
gauche
j'ai pensé j'ai jamais pensé que veulent
partir et comme il est parti
si vous voulez pour moi les deux départs
de de gaulle doivent conduire pas
seulement la gauche les français à une
révision sur notre puissance de
prophétie notre intuition de
l'éventuelle puisque nous avions même
exclu ça et à notre analyse politique
savait ya pas que les marxistes qui se
veulent prophète de l'histoire il y
avait des analyses extrêmement
rigoureuse puisque de gaulle était
arrivé comme ça au pouvoir il devait en
sortir de la même manière les précédents
historiques assez curieux à quel point
les gens qui ne croient pas à la marche
de l'histoire se servent quelquefois des
précédents de l'histoire est là le
départ de de gaulle se faisant comme une
sorte de caprice démocratique
souveraineté de consensus la décision de
solitude je crois beaucoup à la vie sa
version malraux qu'elle je crois que
entre ces deux hommes il s'est passé
quelque chose qui est au delà d
interprétation réaliste je construis
side
cole volontaire avec leurs effets rasa
même si c'est qu'on trouvait par un
certain nombre de témoignages qu'il
couve de murville quand je n'y croyais
pas en tout cas
en tout cas là le départ de de gaulle
c'est à dire la volonté de ne pas se
maintenir avec tous les conseils du été
donnée de ne pas lever de légion
indirectes ne pas susciter de troubles
on doit amener ceux qui sont amateurs
recherchent une vérité politique
alors à côté de ça il avait bien sûr que
quand un personnage passe dans
l'histoire comme de gaulle c'est comme
une série personnage coiffe au palais il
faut pas les rater alors je les
regardais des colonisés et puis ya une
chose qui m'a frappé j'en ai terminé
avec ça je m'excuse
chaque fois que moi j'étais par
discipline réticents la gare de de
gaulle qui me ramenait sont les jeunes
du tiers-monde faut savoir ce que ça a
été je passais mon temps voyage était
pratiquement pas à france pendant toutes
ces années là mais du mexique à cuba de
bamako enfin peu partout jeudi au congo
en afrique du nord bien entendu la
jeunesse du tiers monde les plus jeunes
les plus militants les plus radicaux et
les plus violents étaient d'un gaullisme
déconcertant alors chaque fois que je
revenais en france il y avait une sorte
de divorce de jeu je subissais une sorte
de traumatisme
le quasi névrotique c'est un conflit de
vérité
tous les jeunes révolutionnaires du
tiers-monde était gaulliste et plus ils
étaient jeunes plus c'était
révolutionnaire
et puis bien sûr il ya une explication
par l'anti américanisme mais y avait cet
homme à exister par la jeunesse par la
révolution
jean vincent revel ou qui était aussi
dans le camp des anti glisse est ce que
vous avez votre opinion a varié depuis
est-ce que vous pouvez aussi vous avez
commis des erreurs non elle a varié oui
j'ai commis une erreur
roger sous-estimer l'importance de la
création des institutions de la vème
république
donc il est certain que la au départ
j'avais la version disons qu'ils étaient
répandues rive gauche c'est à dire la
version du coup d'état fin même
homologué ensuite dans les élections
mais est en démocratie fonctionne est
une façon un peu curieuse puisque bien
sûr il ya les élections mais d'autre
part les grands mois
la formation audiovisuelle était
monopolisée par voie par l'état et d'une
manière parce qu'on a la mémoire courte
sans comparaison possible beaucoup plus
draconiennes que c'est le cas maintenant
quatre compagnes la télévision française
avant 65 par exemple les ressources
ensuite c'est différent est bon que je
sais que pour que les élections soient
probantes et il faut évidemment que
l'information soit totalement libre ou
tout au moins diverses que donc on
pouvait interpréter la première moitié
de l'histoire à 5 à ma musique comme une
forme de césarisme césarisme n'excluant
pas les élections puisque le contraire
s'appuie sur le bon sens populaire
ensuite il est certes un bon call et les
des institutions survécu à l'homme et
que dans cette partie de l'europe où
parfois on se demande si les classes
politiques tentent à une sorte de
vocations suicidaire n'est pas
impossible que la france où se trouve
être actuellement sûr dans la situation
de l'italie soit celle de la grande
bretagne avait pas par exemple
l'institution présidentielle c'est
incontestable dans nos propres côté bien
les choses que j'ai opposé à des gaules
en particulier dans ce livre qui
s'appelait en france où la fin de
l'opposition quitte 65 qui était un
pamphlet anti gaulliste et anti français
que je maintiens je crois qu'il ya eu en
même temps un certain archaïsme une
organisation française qui se manifeste
maintenant par exemple par le
chauvinisme xénophobie qui ont certes un
certain impact politique négatif à mon
sens dans la question européenne
tout ça doit vous faire plaisir je suis
faire du cat et moi je me suis trompé
aussi sûr je me suis trompé sur de
gaulle moment est arrivé au pouvoir sur
l'algérie je croyais qu'il était un
équilibre
c'est à dire qu'il le risque raid est
emporté je me suis trompée pendant un an
jusqu'au barricades à partir des
barricades
j'ai pensé qu'il ferait l'indépendance
mais il ya là un article là dessus les
sages et mais je me suis pas trompé sur
les institutions par contre dès le début
j'ai pensé qu' il installe et
institutions qui lui survivrait et à
l'époque j'étais très minoritaire mendes
avec qui je travaillais les admissions
donc pas envoyer soumise à l'épreuve
suprême de changement entre parlement
mais elles ont provoqué un certain
nombre de
de mouvement et de vote dans lequel les
français se sont exprimés
oui c'est tout a dit su qu'il avait
raison nous n'avons jamais eu une
assemblée nationale avec une majorité
différente de celle qui a élu président
tant qu'on n'aura pas passé c'était
preuve on ne saura pas s'aimer
institutions de la vème sens afin de
tenir le coup d'arrêt mais j'étais aussi
un discours vers l'opposition lui disant
dans la forme où tu te présentes
je ne veux pas tout c'est vrai
revenons-en livre de guy hocquenghem
alors la beauté du mettis vous vous
dites votre haine de la france guy
hocquenghem que la france ne vous mettez
un petit f
vous dites votre supplice d'être nés
français d'être français et en même
temps vous chanter la beauté du mettis
le type du livre alors est ce que c'est
une thèse très insolente pour faire
effectivement un livre provocateur ou
bien ce que très profondément vous
ressentez cette haine ou contre la
france écoutez c'est une thèse les
écureuils m'a demandé si je mens aussi
je dis la vérité n'a pas retenu que je
vous dise que je mens bon alors c'est
bien je mangeais ce livre uniquement
comme des gens n'ayant donc pas
littéralement se poursuit pour l'instant
je vous parle je précise ma question
simplement il arrive que je fais gaffe
l'été on sépare toujours supporté var
original violence une violence
je veux dire par là que est ce que nos
vous dites des choses qui sont très
dures contre la france bon et c'est une
chance qu'on est en train d'avoir un bon
exemple un si bon du débat de ce soir
en principe bon ça s'appelle les
intellectuels journalistes par exemple
je reviens un peu là dessus ça me paraît
très typique
très français cette appellation
intellectuels journalistes pour désigner
tout simplement les gens qui ont le
pouvoir dans les trois plus grands
hebdomadaires d'opinion français qui
sont traversés existants vous ne vous
êtes ont été tués tout si oui sauf que
j'ai phanou ivoire oui moi je ne suis
pas dans un grand hebdomadaire etc c'est
très important c'est différent c'est ça
les vraies différences ils vraie
différence n'est pas de savoir s'ils
étaient pour ou contre de gaulle vous
avez dit toutes les semaines dans donc
votre hebdo arrêté pour une fois que
quelqu'un qui parle un peu différemment
bon oui d'accord dans une différence de
niveau dans les moyens tout de même ce
qui me paraît typique c'est le type de
discussion que vous tombiez est bien
entendu celle dite de discussion qui a
lieu ici depuis un moment c'est à dire
tout le monde ici s'exprime comme si
c'était des décideurs et ce sont des
décideurs les vrais intellectuels
effectivement c'est vous trois dans la
mesure où c'est vous qui décidez en fait
ce que doit être disons la tendance
intellectuelle du moment c'est très
révélateur à votre livre jean daniel
tout ce que vous dites effectivement sur
sa ligne ci-dessous ce que vous dites
sur la façon dont a commencé ici la
dénonciation du goulag sur ce que vous
dites bon surtout d une chose de gens où
vous avez vous le dit clairement vous
aurez de pratiquement l'inventeur c'est
comme ça que ça se passe les inventeurs
ici c'est pas du tout les gens te crées
oui l'inventeur au sandre je suis le
promoteur mais l'inventeur sujet pour
vous prétendue aventure le coach ou le
les gens importants les vrais
intellectuels en france ne sont pas les
gens qui écrivent des livres ce ne sont
pas les gens qui soutiennent des thèses
sont maintenant les gens que je vais
vivre les réalités de monde ce sont les
gens au moins n est moins sûr du club
anglais ce sont les gens qui ont besoin
d'un rang à l'épreuve pour le contester
j'invente pas dit oui parce que je n'ai
jamais prétendu et inventeur de solides
prétentions stupide je n'ai jamais lu
mais si voilà je te tue notre cul
devrait pouvoir la ceiba peine de le
nier comme moi je veux voir
la vente est solide utile de pouvoir qui
fixe en france la journée l'avion des
vivres et des seaux vides chez de 1962
par les états unis
ici en france les gens qui décident à un
moment donné si les aurais pas ils se
parlent et je vendais de telle ou telle
chose
effectivement ces trois hebdomadaires 2%
des votes repensé pour offrir son
émission spéciale il aurait le meilleur
acteur noir de faire parler de quelque
chose et imposé quelque chose à
l'opinion se prouve que vous l'ignorez
totalement je n'en finis est toujours là
bien des gens qui ont le goût des revues
les gens qui n'en ont pas non plus
laissé que laissait croire à tout le
monde
oui c'est vrai je vous le sortez
simplement c'est parce que vous étiez
représenter d'un autre journal d'un
autre courant d'opinion et d'une
nouvelle génération
alors je veux dire ce que vous avez la
parole là c'est normal
elle nous dit vous pouvez vous exprimer
bon bon alors simplement non mais vous
il ya vous aussi vous avez un quart de
ce pouvoir là qu'est la télévision
actuellement
alors simple non pas j'aurai pour venir
à votre livre vous expliquez votre haine
de la france n'est toujours pas répondu
à ma question vous perdez votre parler
un peu de lui sauf qu'une chose
l'analyste sauf qu'il ya une chose il
faut qu'ils soient solitaire parce que
il joue gagnant nos divisions entre nous
et pour se poser dans une originalité
particulier aucune image de maths
la solitude est une chose importante
j'aurais voulu lui dire que je suis
d'accord avec telle ou telle chose
d'ailleurs je vais vous compromettre de
cette manière tout à l'heure c'est bien
mais non mais non ils ont tous dit une
chose d'important alors vous n'avez ni
pourquoi cette haine de la france parce
que je pense qu'il ya effectivement
parce que je pense que le destin est ce
qu'on peut appeler un destin national
français qui est une chose particulière
qui n'appartient qu'à ce pays si qui est
depuis très longtemps depuis des siècles
depuis on peut discuter le nombre de
siècle disons depuis entre trois et cinq
siècles un pays dans lequel la frontière
culturelle le territoire la langue et
l'état sont unifiés d'une manière totale
se correspondent sont en concordance
totale comme ça n'existe nulle part
ailleurs
je pense que cette prête particulier je
pense que ça explique en grande partie
la xénophobie fondamentale française
un exemple on dit souvent que les états
unis sont un pays raciste par exemple
on pense souvent que la france n'est pas
un pays raciste un phénomène récurent
rieussec par exemple la les noirs
américains jouent un rôle très important
dans la culture contemporaine américaine
aussi bien musicalement que
littérairement que dans tous les
domaines culturels
il ya ici en france 1 million ou vue
d'être plus de travailleurs immigrés
maghrébins il ya une longue relation de
la france avec les pays arabes
il n'y a strictement aucune mixité aucun
mélange aucune apparition culturelle de
ce que j'appellerais l'arabité ou de la
présence arabe en france à l'intérieur
culture française n'y a pas de métissage
en france il ya une espèce de deux
solitudes or là au sens propre de
fermeture juste une question votre idole
de tous âges aux états unis oui il ya un
métissage culturel neige
enfin les états unis dont un melting-pot
sépare les nouveau nés est ce tu nous as
et il devrait de communauto juste cause
et le multi le poteau l'on sait qu'il
est très particulier des salles alors je
me souviendrai particulier andré
mariages mixtes
oui on connaissait des interprétations
plus en plus comme certaines sociétés
artistique je veux dire extrêmement
extrêmement particulière mais mais je
suis complètement d'accord avec avec
cloclo dessus avec vous d'accord
d'accord sur la toile un livre froid
contre ce texte qui était publié en 1977
appel dit markus züst en sièges et sans
qui ont largement par amour là qu'elle a
toujours et à livrer nos va être
d'ailleurs un grand mais c'est très bien
d'accent vous avez dit alors qu'aulas
autre autre raison de haïr la france ça
la première la seconde raison c'est que
je pense que l'univers culturel français
d'un univers particulier cet univers est
essentiellement dominé dans les phrases
de joseph de maistre que je cite qui me
paraît très révélatrice il dit la france
me casse pas la domination par les
armées l'exercent la divination par
l'opinion et j'y reviens effectivement
parce que les gens qui sont ici sont les
gens qui font l'opinion l'opinion s'est
plaisamment le commentaire c'est le
second temps il ya le temps de l'action
il ya le temps de l'opinion je pense
qu'à une particularité française qui est
que ce qu'on vit en france est
essentiellement le commentaire des
actions d'autrui ce très curieux en
france
le rôle des intellectuels de gauche en
particulier qui est perpétuellement de
commenter ce qui se passe ailleurs qu'il
s'agisse du goulag
qu'il s'agisse des luttes bon comme au
liban ou ou au cambodge et serra et se
sont prises de position sur prise de
position et ce sans commentaire sur
commentaires et opinions sur l'opinion
ce sont des donneurs de leçons permanent
et ça ça me paraît une caractéristique
culturelle française cette espèce de
situation vous donner une sacrée leçon
non frasques leçons à tirer et les flics
j'essaie d'expliquer aux français ce qui
n'est pas évident parce qu'il n'est pas
facile de situer en extériorité en
écrivant française évident j'essaye des
de relativiser c'est à dire d'expliquer
comment en fait on ne se rend pas compte
à quel point on vit dans un monde fermé
en france
à quel point le monde intellectuel
français est fermé à quel point guette
et 3 et ça c'est difficile à expliquer
effectivement ça pose un problème je
pense bon j'en fais est alors eu lieu
quand vous dites yens contre les
centristes évident il y en a une je ne
nie pas une contradiction essayé
d'expliquer sa expliqué qu'on vit dans
une cellule et à l'expliquer sur les
murs de cette cellule c'est pas évident
je reconnais que c'est une chose
difficile est paradoxal par moments je
pense que c'est important que les gens
le réaliser en particulier dont le lait
français les jeunes français dans la
mesure où c'est particulièrement
difficile pour un français d'aller à
l'étranger que toute notre culture nous
interdit aussi bien nous empêche ou nous
paralyse dans l'émigration dans le
métissage
elle nous enseigne avant tout la
méfiance de l'étranger la xénophobie
l'histoire politique française s'établit
d'abord pas sur la haine de l'étranger
moi je regroupe frito lay there danger
avant quoi tous les jours la ruse et moi
je réponds j'avoue que j'ai un super ce
qui me fascine chez la génération des 25
ans c'est l'extraordinaire rapidité
qu'ils ont et facilité qu'ils ont
affrontés sur les frontières
leur aisance partout le fait qu' ils
sont à la fois français et à la fois à
l'aise en allemagne en angleterre en
amérique et qu'il trouve immédiatement
des répondants et qu'ils trouvent leur
langage et engage comme un meilleur
presque international qui est une espèce
de vitalité française qui n'est plus
dans l'hexagone fermé et qui pour la
première fois se passe et au moment où
vous écrivez un livre qui était vrai il
ya 25 ans mais il n'a pas du tout
vitalité français ya une vie de qualité
effectivement général une vitalité
général les échanges culturels par
jeunes aujourd'hui une partie du bourg
l'aller n'ont pas l'air de manière plus
sereine de ce livre qui est très bien
décrit encore une fois dans la langue la
plus heureuse et la plus classique la
plus bourgeoise qui soit mais très bien
écrit et vraiment très très bien écrit
et bien moi je suis d'accord valable
aujourd'hui trop parce qu'il n'y a qu'un
seul français dans les troubles m non
puisque vous employez un autre dans libé
était très unie
si vous permettez alors j'ai besoin pour
parler du fond du problème et pas de
vous et vous parlez de votre livre avec
le sait résister je trouve que s'est
exprimé il ya toute une partie moi où je
me suis sentie entretien monsieur santi
exprimer c'était pas nouveau mais se
sentir exprimé une nouvelle fois c'est
bien et quand cet homme dans cette
langue c'est tout à fait un plaisir
pourquoi le métissage l'éloge de la
bâtardise c'est une partie de ma vie
regretté que les juifs berbères n'évacue
sous la poussée de certaines influences
les montagnes de l'atlas en enlevant une
racine regretté que les coptes et les
maltais parts du caire ou de tunis
regrettait que tous et mixité dans le
monde ne se fasse pas j'ai toujours
belle pensée ça en plus une certaine
influence gidienne qui peut-être du fait
il se trouve en effet que certaines
conduites enfin conduite jeudi rigide
yen approche dans une sorte de nostalgie
cette mixité
enfin la france la la la
comment le caractère chauvin et
xénophobe d'une partie une grande partie
de la france était évident on peut pas
compter six finales et trouve cette
visite est simple alors assisté à un
contrôle d'identité dans le milieu de
vie de mieux contrôler et étrangers pas
seulement en tant que supplément
étrangers est pour toi il sera temps et
hélas où il a encore raison c'est que
c'est pour ça que je voulais le lit
conduire c'est que contrairement aux
etats-unis le seuil d'intolérance n'est
pas du tout atteint en france
à la rigueur nous qui sommes si sévère
avec les reins site a mérité nous
pourrions faire des analyses sur ce
qu'on appelle en biologie le seuil
d'intolérance ou l'espace particulier
mais c'est vrai qu'en france il ya des
réactions de rejet qui sont très
particulières alors qu'est ce qui m'a
gêné par pour finir fort pour ne pas
finir sur une approbation sans réticence
de cette manière on après le petit
agression original et bien qu est ce qui
m'a gêné c'est que c'est vrai que vous
glissez il vous fallait une icône dur
les autres c'était des icônes mode qui
avait déjà été détruites les gones dur
c'est la littérature et vous vous êtes
adressé à cet effet le couple et fameux
de l'opposition entre la tradition
classique en camisole et par malherbe
boileau et puis je sais laquelle on peut
vous opposez rabelais sa de céline lalau
très grand et c'est ça c'est vrai la
seule chose vous oublié c'est que la
littérature française est probablement
notre porte quand même sur l'extérieur
pour vous parler votre pion au terrain
et qui est intéressant de mai
dostoïevski
il est emparé de balzac est ce que vous
savez que ne passe que vous vous
rappelez vous le savez bien sûr mais
c'est un dante pas connu quand denis
chang en a fait une sorte de folie de
personnel un sketch paix et diderot
qu'ils offrent ici sinon goethe et
schiller jeudi la littérature française
a été pendant des td des siècles une
ouverture les tripes pour quand même
l'habitude s'est agi d'un glissement ou
je crois que vous avez fait avec chose
qu'on peut tout de même pour s'impliquer
extrêmement dire qu' il existe une
spécificité française
suite aux spécificités l'a peut-être
qu'on peut dire que par exemple la chine
avait qu'une chose de ce genre là
pendant longtemps en se considérant
comme le centre du monde
je suis mais bon la chine c'est très
vaste ça vous expliquer par d'autres
choses mais ce qui est particulier à la
france c'est de même que tous les
conflits mondiaux que toutes les
attitudes sont totalement la donne at il
ajouté très c'est très contemporain ce
que je veux dire c'est à dire que nous
soyons aujourd'hui coindeau et se rendre
par exemple se font à nouveau
non mais je ne cherche pas faire le du
nouveau ses problèmes c'est de mettre en
avant
quelque chose qui n'est pas à ce qui
n'est pas connu en france parce que la
france se tait sur sa propre fermeture
et le dis très rarement et le dis très
marginalement et je dis que nous parlons
les insurgés disent que nous dénonçons
le faire autour de fonds jean marc
dumontet
j'aurais bien meuble sévère d'argent
niveau puisque vous me tâter le 6
janvier à libération une chose que je
voudrais vous dire clairement ce que ça
vaut peut-être mieux sur lequel j'avais
eu vent en ambition secrète d'un livre
qui compte un peu pour moi chaque chose
pourquoi pas c'était d'une réflexion
sous jacentes sur la violence et je
regrette que ici n'était même violence
que vern par une violence dont ils
rigolent est ce que l'un des personnages
je suis faire des eaux censier merida il
n'y a qu'une chasse royale et c'est
celle de la vérité
est ce que vous faites vos sur cette
phrase oui sauf que j'aime pas
d'employer les bocaux priorité non plus
l'absence et le vrai oui mais comme je
l'expliqué dans la préface je pense que
le vrai c'est une limite disparition
qu'en fait dans le domaine de la
formation la seule ce garde-fou c'est la
diversifier il faut préserver la
diversité vérité personne aujourd'hui
j'aime la diversité oui
bon quelques ouvrages pour terminer le
quatrième volume des frustrés de claire
bretécher collaboratrice de mme et
d'observateurs vient de paraître
un numéro spécial de la nef où va la
gauche avec avec jean-daniel avec eux
aussi votre ami commun revel et daniels
a dit rené andrieu benameur bertrand
poirot-delpech et d'autres redditions
livre de poche de pourquoi des
philosophes suivi de la kabbale des
dévots de jean françois revel signale
que le mal français d'alain peyrefitte
vient de paraître un livre de poche
et puis pour terminer les sciences
humaines d'aujourd'hui fiction raid
c'est sont des entretiens avec des
intellectuels de jacques rousseau avec
des gens aussi différents que raymond
aron jacques attali balandier claude
lévi-strauss etc
bonsoir à tous à vendredi prochain
[Musique]